David I forgot to tell you but meaning
to tell you this do I forget every time
I told you did you know that my daughter
just got accepted to Harvard I did not
know that you're a science Norris on it
congratulate our strange but we're
estranged but yeah yeah the kid the kid
got a big brain she got yeah yeah how
did you find out if I may ask how did
you find out given that your estranged
oh that's my I had somebody go on her on
her mother's Facebook and her mother's
Facebook has Harvard mom and all this
and and I went on Julia's Facebook and
that she just posted one little thing
about Harvard you know like the kids not
real big äj-- she's very humble I mean
the kid yeah kids never missed a day of
school she's she wants to be a scientist
and Jimmy I I mean I'm really sorry I'm
really sorry that your estranged from
her why how did that happen I'm curious
well you know that email I sent you
right with all that you know I mean no I
want to put it out but uh would email
but uh the mother put the mother was a
50-day drinker much worse than I ever
was I've never had to be detox but but
Jimmy if their mother drinks how did you
get it how did you get a song trained oh
I say with that she so the mother was
drinking and made claims about you the
mother made a bunch of false claims
which I was exonerated after 18 months
yeah she sat through the baby on the
floor her putting the kid was nine
months old there was no evidence to this
right but did you do aside from whether
there was evidence did you out of my
apartment what that aside from whether
there was evidence did you do that did
you throw a baby on the floor no of
course not even my kid when she was five
years old she said daddy wouldn't I have
gotten hurt if you threw me okay you
would think you know but you know that's
the way the court system works today
David if a woman said something or even
the man I mean if you're the first one
to make the accusation that's what they
go with Jimmy let me ask you this
curious walk-and-talk Jimmy have you
have you um have you been arrested
before
of course I what were the charges what
were you arrested for I'm not gonna tell
you but the danger is with violence
against any forty years ago this was 35
years ago no violence against anybody
now Oh with I mean just generally
speaking what kind of a thing wasn't
let's say that theft and we're firearms
but I don't want to make that as an
excuse because you know I was guilty as
hell and uh you know that's not
something I'm proud of
yeah but you know I'm not doing that now
I mean yeah here's another thing so I
was an idiot over twitch prime but
you're getting all these calls about
yeah like they don't understand twitch
prime but I wasn't [ __ ] yeah do not all
right Jimmy Jimmy I'm feeling bad about
all this it's a sad situation I'm an
atheist you're an atheist right yeah
yeah you're an atheist right so how come
you didn't come at this Pelosi thing
where she said she's a Catholic and she
doesn't hate anybody how come you didn't
come at that from the atheistic point of
view oh yeah why you let her get a pat
all right Jimmy very good we'll listen I
hope that I all the best
I hope they reconnect with her I do hope
you reconnect with her all right thank
you very much Jimmy from Philly
somebody please clip that some of it
something something sad about that call
today